oggi mi sento un anziano alla fermata
del pullman ve lo ricordate quel periodo
in cui quando guardavo una puntata di
walker texas ranger nessuno ti rompere i
[ __ ] con nessuna battuta su chuck
norris o il periodo in cui andare a
vedere un film di michael bay non
comportasse il linciaggio da parte dei
tuoi amici si succedeva era il periodo
prima di internet o meglio internet
esisteva già ma non era una rottura di
[ __ ] visitarlo ora tutti fanno
battute su chuck norris tutti odiano
michael bay perché internet alla fine è
come quel tuo amico che continua a
cambiare le dimensioni del suo pene di
storia in storia talmente tante volte
che alla fine non riesce più a capire
qual è la verità e qual è la bugia e
quindi mi sono posto una domanda quante
volte è morto crilin eh sì perché se tu
vai a vedere su internet tutti fanno
battute su crilin che muore ma amava
resuscitate lo sa ma morirà anche nella
nuova stagione di dragon ball super
sì ma quanti sanno effettivamente quante
volte molto crilin cinque o sei una
quindicina 138mila neanche io ne ero
così sicuro quindi sono andato a
controllare e ho scoperto che crilin è
ufficialmente morto cinque volte cinque
morti si ma a fronte di 500 episodi eh
sì perché se noi contiamo 153 episodi di
dragon ball della serie originale 291
della serie z e 64 del gt fanno
esattamente 508 episodi in italia
ovviamente
e cazzo cinque morti nomi sembrano così
tante ma vogliamo proprio andare a
cercare il pelo nell'uovo una morte
avviene nell'universo alternativo quindi
in teoria per la storyline principale
non conta e poi muore per mano di super
c 17 in dragon ball gt che
universalmente nessuno prende in
considerazione quindi le morti che
possiamo considerare effettive del mio
cliente sono tre la morte contro
tamburello magari più giovani non se lo
ricordano ma tamburello era il figlio di
al satan o grande mago piccolo nel male
dove viene ucciso già vestito elegante
pronto per la bara la morte nell'ultima
parte di dragon ball z contro burgo dove
crisi viene trasformato in una barretta
di cioccolato e mangiato è poi quella
più famosa che conoscono tutti contro
freezer visto alla fine sono solo 3 non
è così grave e alla fine tutte e tre in
un modo o nell'altro sono stati
importanti come morti giusto per
ricordarvi la morte contro frise porta
alla trasformazione di cocoon super
sayan secondo me ci sono personaggi che
meriterebbero molto di più di essere
presi per il culo uno fra tutti cazzo di
rif
oh mio dio lui muore facendosi saltare
in aria contro nappa si sacrifica per
ucciderlo e non gli fa neanche un
graffio e l'esplosione e rosa porca
[ __ ] rief quanto devi essere inutile
insomma livescribe ha long
ci sono cose molto più gravi secondo me
tipo un ventisettenne che parla di
dragon ball no per davvero mi sto
annoiando quest'estate